- My heart went out to the people that
produced this stuff in
all of our bad times,
but especially fine
orchestras and then dancers,
people that do that and you,
- Thank you.
- I just amazed at what you people do
and how you express it.
It's art and love and design and movement.
(crowd cheering)
- It's beautiful to see
your body flowing like that.
And that's so cool that y'all get to do
the father, daughter.
I thought that was really special.
- What book?
Tell them, remember that book you read?
- Yeah, it was literally
called Misty Copeland.
- Ah my god.
- I had a book that I read when I was like
- Just saw her backstage
and the look on her face.
- She's like.
- I was like.
Who, who?
- Oh my gosh, that's so funny.
We didn't know that. That's so.
- Every morning like I would, I was,
I don't know probably like
seven or eight years old
and my mom and I, we used
to read books to like
while she was making breakfast.
And I had, it was just like,
you know, picture books
like a kid's picture book.
But I read it every morning.
- Oh my God.
- Like every morning.
- I love that.
- So when I heard, I was like.
Who?
- Sitting right next to her.
Just take it in.
Take it in.